qui de ces pousses à soulever les yeux
quand vous dansiez le moule à ce dieu
quand il a fait froid qui est allé vous
cherchez du peu c'est l'un des nouveaux
au soleil
aulas sont pour l'instant les jours sont
plus longs et plus beau j'ai attiré la
brise pour les sabres vous rendre
heureux ce matin
comment vous le dire certains
composé d
m
soc
oui
or
il remplit
hier générations entre familles a vécu
en sécurité sur cette île paisible mais
au delà du récif un danger nos menaces
la légende parle d'ailleurs
qui sillonnera l'océan à la recherche du
demi dieu mao
ensemble ils pourront nous sauver
nous l eau l eau est non
ah oui
bah oui mais d'abord demi dieu du vent
et de la mer
je suis le goal des hommes en fait c'est
ma wii mais ta mort demi dieu du vent et
de la mer et dole des sommes jetés
interrompu désolé recommence idole des
hommes à toi partir en mission et qu'une
gamine pas question ça fait ma fille
rock et tu vas venir jusqu'à technique
alors ça j'ai pas vu venir
l'océan est mon ami
premièrement on va devoir traverser un
océan de malheurs les cas camorra les
cacas quoi ils sont trop mignons
rayhana je te couvre bah oui le retour
non c'est pas vrai une fléchette dans la
fesse
nous allons au royaume des mousses
trafolle pas c'est encore bien pire que
ce que tu crois